[Music]
hello everyone
tony decided to take a break from
youtube and chess
he will stream uh fortnight
and until he decides what to do in the
future fortnite or chess
i'll be taking over
but luckily it's not the mailman it's
yelena and i didn't do any videos
yesterday
i was really busy we were picking grapes
you know because
all that wine is not going to make
itself something very peculiar happened
today
my girlfriend and i were watching a
movie and all of a sudden
a door bell rang so when i came to see
who it was there was actually no one
there
all i could find was this this
skull thing here it was on the doorstep
uh there was no message or anything so
that's
that's really weird what do you think
the idea here is
sorry i'm uh i'm a bit a bit out of
breath i was uh
doing some light exercises and i thought
i thought it'd be a good idea to do a
video right after that but apparently
it's not so let me just
like take 10 seconds i don't have my
water ready
the glass is empty i forgot to refill it
you know
it's silly me yeah really really weird
stuff
magnus with the white pieces opens with
uh e4
uh or does he no he doesn't i'm pretty
sure it's a d4 yeah he opens with
d4 and uh
bishop to h6 preventing black from
castling
uh knight captures on e5 knight captures
on e5
knight captures on e5 knight to c3
characters on e5
it was really a wild clash in the end
yeah losing i mean
i think that's no i mean i think
you are married yes no i'm not married
you're not married no no i'm single were
you ever married
no i was not ever married really i i
totally remember like reading that uh
you were married no nope uh okay okay
okay
that uh that that's really weird it's
like the
the mandela effect or something i mean
it seems like uh seems like a perfectly
reasonable blunder
charlie was very impressed with with
himself he said that this must be
some sort of a record he was uh he he
inquired as uh
to what uh is actually the chat saying
my couches is throbbing throbbing what
is xqc's chat saying right now
uh and so on it's a minor difference but
it is a big difference
uh but you know in the in this uh
uh you know uh
in this uh struggle
how do you find two and a half men
ah not really funny sometimes but
like uh i think from one to five
um like two and a half maybe one
and a half i see what you did there you
know pretty good stuff
and now uh i think any one of you could
play this position against karpov and
you know you would not lose it's going
to be really exciting
to see what what geary will do uh now
that he
defeated magnus carlsen we're probably
going to hear a lot about it
on twitter for for forever okay i'm
playing good chess
with a beard i'm not gonna be shaving my
beard uh
de presnyuk ah ghost of tsushima what is
this
how why
what just happened here
sorry what is this leeches what
oh he pre-set the position oh wow he
tricked me the general consensus was
that
you want at least one rook on e1 uh
this is probably the most poisonous rook
that that ever
uh strolled the e file
is that a [ __ ] is that a country
is lord of the back door
getting backdoored here uh a queen is
very powerful when the
when the king is naked usually i'd never
ask you to pause the video and
solve the position you see on the board
i'll give you a lot of seconds
uh a lot of i'll give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding such a
nice mate in five
uh glad it's not a mate and eight we
have too much rhymes
as it is on this channel uh and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
uh break break up this chain get the
knight back into the game but what
happened in this game
is just uh it is just a shame an
extremely tough opponent and
it was at this moment it's young versus
uh sorry about that will be a part of
the attack sort of a
six-fold repetition but yeah it was in
this position bishop to d6 by on google
push up the b5 check
nonetheless out of creativity out of
calculation not out of preparation
rook to e2 is very strong going after
the bishop going after the g2 pawn you
have to move it
if you move it unless you don't you want
to lose it what's when it didn't go for
f4 still wants to win this game he
doesn't want to draw
there's another threat as queen captures
and g5 will come with check but who
knows
it's a big game so uh anything goes you
can't move the world because you'll lose
the knight
this would be easily winning for white
black has to react his queen is under
attack forced
mate in 13 and black isn't greedy for
not
giving up the point that's considered to
be one of the greatest blunders of his
career
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
[Music]
[Applause]
and still still still the mate is uh you
know delivered on h8 and again we have
the rhyme so
yeah it's unavoidable i can't find my
book uh on capablanca uh my girlfriend
was uh
moving things around and and it's just
uh nowhere to be found
oh sorry about that
captures captures you're gonna go
captures captures captures captures and
now
captures captures captures captures
captures and now captures captures
only move queen captures captures
captures so the reason i really enjoyed
this game is because
captures captures the last video in the
copa blanca saga will be
the last video in the capoblanca saga
it's always better to
to give up your queen than to win your
opponent's queen rook to a1
i'm making room for the white king on b1
but still rook to c2 checkmate
king to b1 and now knight to f1 we have
king the g8
getting the king out of the way but for
now stockfish's rook is
non-existent there is no rook
and i always remember what kramnik said
after after he lost the kramnik
and it doesn't make sense uh but also
doesn't
i could maybe record the videos in a
bathrobe that might not be actually have
a pretty nice bathrobe
like it'd be so much more comfortable
and uh
but yeah we'd have to really be careful
not to you know
not to get any nasty discoveries
i cannot find uh any evidence of this
footage uh other than
you know people in forum asking what
happened to the footage which is very
strange because
well popular videos don't just disappear
from youtube
are you sure about that so f3 then
strengthens the pawn says okay i'm gonna
capture now
but gary says no you don't okay i'm
gonna grab on d6 on the next move but
giri says no you're not okay uh i'm
probably gonna capture on the next move
uh but gary says nope in an end game a
rook and bishop
is always a rook and bishop most of the
times and here we have also a nice photo
of nippo just
you know fixing the volume he's sorry
about that it's not an easy move to find
it's hard to say if it's even the
greatest move
i mean he does look kind of weird i
don't know what's so wrong with him but
[Applause]
[Music]
like like the honey badger he simply
doesn't care look at all the dark
squares
and i don't think nasa ground control
wants to allow this as
greg is an astronaut uh astronaut so i
don't think he
he will have a problem uh exploiting the
space left behind
uh in this position uh the better player
is better
so depending on what you play and how
you decide to defend this
you know you will either win or not win
this game knight captures on h5 was not
played
it seems seems very suspicious you know
so that's some uh
three rating points above uh above
magnus currently second
and uh something
not not at all weird
[Music]
yeah i don't know why sometimes the tv
just uh
starts starts by itself and everything
gets traded off captures captures
captures captures captures
captures captures and captures and you
are playing the same game
so definitely a strong player magnus
crossing
and that's why i decided to use this
title i don't know
seems to seem like an appropriate thing
to do uh but he
uh forgot one very important thing uh
and that's uh
i'm captain jack sparrow does hikaru
pronounce
uh agar matar correctly no he doesn't
i i think he pronounces it like a guy
mature i think something like that
when it's in fact agad mator without any
any weird stuff going on it's just me
and you it's me and you yeah oh it's one
okay okay okay here
antonio will put this on his channel or
not because he might
wait uh
what oh come on
seriously e6 loses the game on the
screen rematch
i will look for you i will find you
i'm either gonna capture and capture or
if you capture then i'm gonna capture
and after captures captures i just
wanted to mention that uh haha it's
very funny that uh you you laughed at me
in the comments for
uh someone trolling me uh with a funny
name in the contribution but
you know you also have to consider it's
an 11 minute video of me making an idiot
of myself
uh you can see two of my previous videos
here
uh thank you all for watching uh you can
show this
beautiful game to your friends in a bar
or library or something
thank you all for watching and see you
[Music]
tomorrow
[Music]
you